the theatre company behind New York's
famous Shakespeare in the park is
playing defense after major sponsors
pulled out of its new production of
Julius Caesar the public theaters play
features a present trump look-alike in
the title role he's shown being stabbed
to death on stage Delta Airlines decided
to end its partnership Bank of America
pulled its sponsorship of the production
Jaime waxes in New York's Central Park
outside the theater where Julius Caesar
officially opened last night
Jaime good morning good morning yes
every summer all 1,800 seats in this
theater are filled by a non-paying
audience and corporate sponsorship is
essential to keeping that deal going the
theater company is standing by its
interpretation of the play and its
artistic director says that the
production in no way advocates violence
towards anyone for more than 400 years
william shakespeare's julius caesar has
been a lightning rod this year's
adaptation by a New York City theatre
company is no different it features a
president Trump look-alike who is
stabbed to death on stage a modern take
on Shakespeare's classic play artistic
director of the public theater Oskar
Eustis addressed last night's opening
night crowd like drama democracy depends
on the conflict of different points of
view nobody owns the truth we all own
the culture Bank of America backed out
of its sponsorship because the Public
Theater chose to present Julius Caesar
in such a way that was intended to
provoke and offend Delta Airlines
severed its relationship to saying
they're artistic and creative direction
crossed the line on the standards of
good taste the danger here is that once
you start pulling funding or giving
funding based on the content of a
particular piece of art you're getting
into a value judgement on Twitter the
president's son Erik Trump thanked the
companies for their decision calling it
the right thing to do if a play like
Julius Caesar can essentially be
punished for what some have said is an
offensive production what else could
happen here when Shakespeare premiered
the play around $15.99 it was seen as a
provocative take on unease at the end of
Queen
it's rain orson welles later presented
to play in the 1930s with visual
references to Hitler and Mussolini and
destruction in 1988 the Public Theater
produced Julius Caesar with Al Pacino as
Mark Antony and Martin Sheen as Brutus
despite the current controversy there is
plenty of interest at the box office I
don't think it advocates violence
against Trump or anything like that
it's a classic play that they've updated
in a way that has more meaning to us if
the character is dressed like Trump
interestingly in 2012 Delta Airlines
gave financial backing to a production
in Minneapolis of Julius Caesar which
seemed to reference then President Obama
but that production didn't get anything
near this type of attention what's
remarkable about Julius Caesar is that
it always seems to echo the political
environment in which it's produced Gale
all right Thank You Jaime